Ben: This is where you but
Interviewer: Hi, Ben, can you hear me?
Ben: Hello! How are you doing.
Ben: hey? So I'm doing good. How about you. How are you doing? Good, doing good?
Interviewer: Alright.
Interviewer: So. Have you been able to install both of the
Interviewer: yep. Unfortunately, I was able to install the money manager. I was not able to install the other one.
Interviewer: Okay, what was the issue with that room?
Ben: I kept saying, like.
Ben: Check your Internet connection, or something like that.
Interviewer: check your Internet collection.
Ben: Yeah, check your Internet connection and try again.
Interviewer: where are you using a drive link or a dropbox link to download the I was using the the
Ben: the drive length that was in the
Ben: that was in the you know the request details.
Interviewer: So you you weren't able to download it or were, was it just the installation?
Interviewer: I mean, if you can show me yeah, I mean, like.
Ben: show you what I did. So let me.
I think that's yeah.
Ben: 1B s, I'm just going to the
Ben: 1B s.
perfect. Okay? Connecting. Okay.
Ben: I'm just going to the
Interviewer: yeah, the the email I'm using.
Ben: Yeah, thank you.
Magic. Thank you.
I second, thank you. I didn't. What's it next time any other holds.
Ben: like, all right.
Ben: So
and we don't
let's get.
Ben: I was able to download the money manager on. Alright.
Ben: I'm gonna click on this one. Okay.
Ben: are they? The
Ben: the note, the the notes. Cry it up. You said, right?
Interviewer: Yeah, and then subscribe.
okay, that's what I'm say. Second. but I'll take it. Expansion.
I think it'll continue to to
exactly. You can turn the next. I should use this. Okay.
Ben: excuse me.
Interviewer: can you open in Browser?
Yeah, I guess. Probably have. Okay.
I'll be multiplying 0. Because if I'm sorry
Interviewer: stuff you like
dynamic.
But you know.
second time.
with 98 0% next time.
Interviewer: Is there any way to provide you with a new link that you can download from.
Ben: Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
Interviewer: How how do I do that?
Ben: Can you? Can you put it in the zoom, the zoom chat.
Interviewer: Oh, yeah, sure.
See what's in. I'm sorry.
That might be
exactly.
Interviewer: Yeah. I sent it to you.
Ben: My, let me just
fund of 6 months
19.
Ben:  turn it.
Second, it's okay
Ben: in the window
Ben: right there.
And as I pull that
Ben: all the time, but
I mean, like, I mean.
Interviewer: can you save it?
Table button?
Bye, bye.
Interviewer: yeah. Plus store in your phone.
Ben: Okay? Sorry. I'm just
Interviewer: kind of find the.
I can see it. But I finished copy
Ben: 1B s
library.
Ben: I'm trying to find it real quick.
But if I could say for 5 DVD,
Google library Webinar.
exactly. But
Ben: you know, and I'm just not to go back into the
Ben: exported them.
I think jokes nice meeting
Ben: save to device.
and also chose to play. And that's why
like it?
Table? Do you think I need it? Because it was a
Ben: that's the 98%.
That's because I need a button.
Ben: There we go taking a while.
Interviewer: That's all right. I'm I'm just.
Interviewer: I don't know why
Interviewer: it does all that stuff.
Okay, I needed.
Professor. plus 30 bucks, that's all
that's awesome. the most coming up. But last time it's all yeah, it's all yeah.
Ben: I don't know.
It's all right. I mean, I think, like, I mean.
Interviewer: okay, can you open it? Just to be sure, it says, no scrubbers installed.
Ben: Okay?
And I take home
the network city.
fill up the castle. He doesn't.
And Gds device, that's gonna be
okay. Okay.
Interviewer: yeah, okay, nice.
Interviewer: Don't have to do anything. Right now, I'll just initiate our interview.
Interviewer: Alright.
Interviewer: Okay? So first of all. Thank you for making your time to speak with me.
Interviewer: and before we dive in I want to say that the conversation is being recorded, and it will span about 60B min. So
Ben: hopefully you're comfortable with that. Yes, yes.
Interviewer: and I know I've made you before, but had to reintroduce myself. I'm  and I'm .
Interviewer: And today for our research, I'd like to analyze the accessibility and usability of the open source android application, money management, the first step.
Interviewer: So a brief introduction to money manager. It is as the I think you've already used it, but it's something to keep track of your expenses.
Interviewer: and the features include adding or deleting transactions and income. You can create budget plans to keep
Interviewer: track of your spending, and the app also provides analysis of your spending.
Interviewer: And before we open money manager we have to open, or we have to set up note Scribe, and that app is strictly for our research purposes. What it does. It is a background service that tracks like your interaction with money manager app and with. We would later with for a research, try to analyze like the user interaction.
Ben: Okay?
Interviewer: And after setting that up, I will ask you to explore and use the money manager app without any instructions from me. So I just want you to free form. Explore that
Interviewer: during this exploration phase please think aloud. It is essential for our research that you speak your mind continuously about what you are doing, what you're experiencing. So
Ben: okay.
Interviewer: in this phase, if you encounter any obstacle, and blockers.
Interviewer: Take some time to explore a solution.
Interviewer: You can abandon a task if you find it impossible, but I won't intervene.
Interviewer: After you think you have export the app substantially, or our time starts running out, I will ask you to conduct certain tests like I will come into play in this phase.
Interviewer: and at the end of that phase I will ask you to revise the accessibility and usability issues that you encounter.
Okay.
Interviewer: you have any questions or any clarifications in it.
Ben: No, that's it.
Interviewer: Okay, nice. And if you need any break, or just stop anything with me. Okay, alright. So let's set up. Let's go to the notes product, which you're already in.
Interviewer: and let's start. Let's click the start service button.
Interviewer: So you'll have to give yeah. The
Interviewer: what do you call it?
Interviewer: Permission for? No script.
Interviewer: It's the third act. There we go.
Ben: because we know what you say is about your people.
Interviewer: Oh, no, strictly.
Interviewer: Sitting as a second.
Interviewer: Huh?
Interviewer: See?
Interviewer: Is there a way to configure your setting
Ben: update? But but definitely but definitely, I would just keep it with those people, just those my service! Off with those.
Ben: So was it. I'm sorry today.
Ben: but like but it might be.
Ben: But but repeat the loop.
Ben: Have you actually got another big skip?
Okay.
Ben: okay? I can say so.
Ben: But definitely, definitely
Ben: at statistics.
That's fine. That's fine. And then I don't.
Ben: Nobody's
Ben: be fine. Add that usage. Okay.
Ben: you know, without speaking text. And I was speaking tangs.
Interviewer: they're trying to get authentic data online. But but
we're not going, but
Ben: potentially happy. You know my first.
that I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm have a mic to actually hold your mic.
Ben: Pull out tonight. Pull out.  I mean.
Interviewer: okay.
Interviewer: thank you so much. Thanks so much.
Interviewer: overhead we have to do because of it. But thank you for going through that? Alright.
Interviewer: Yep.
Interviewer: can you? Now open the money manager
Ben: and start exploring
for most people
Ben: I don't need. Yes.
Ben: yes.
Ben: basically, basically.
that's okay. Watch it. But every
Ben: one's expenses.
Ben: You're expected as much
Ben: total expenses and expenses by the annotation plus your expenses. If money
Ben: open navigation board
Ben: money, manager expenses, budget categories, budget analysis, monthly expenses, analysis, project plans.
Ben: budget plans, go to budget, budget, check. What's the buddy mentor budget category budget category check open navigation for
Ben: or Japan morage's category. Name
budget it. I'm legal, but
Ben: annotation button icon, add button, icon, add button. double type activation labels, available. Use that with open navigation for but Budget board, category game
Ben: more. Budget, open navigation board.
Ben: money mentor, much expenses, injected budget, budget analysis.
level type that aggregate open
Ben: budget analysis, more options. Thank you for the analysis for more information.
Ben: Visit our web annotation, but visit our website with a money manager, navigate
money mentor. What's budget check budget? What's the expected analysis? Budget plans? What's leading open navigate
Ben: monthly more options left you annotation. But nephew, with a money manager once leaves open them.
But over time it
project project canceled
Ben: the money for the plan.
You want to make the money for the plan that might obviously be back. But that might be planned back.
Ben: I got a vision, but I don't know double back to activation alright. That makes sense
Ben: pneumonic disease more options
Ben: with you wanted to add above settings
quote options, but they're willing to do anything, but they're willing to. but that one obviously can't ask
Ben: you all open Navigation board. But but what you meant, or what's these spaces?
Monthly budget budget ad monthly monthly.
Ben: What's expected to be open? You explained this much more options.
metal thermology, adding up second navigation
Ben: settings, attached
Ben: money, venture more options.
Ben: So that was great. Alright.
Ben: So I explored all the all the tabs at the you know of this half.
Interviewer: What do you think about it?
Ben: I think that it's clearly, you know, it's it's clearly labeled and most things are.
Ben: you know, clearly, clearly labeled
Ben:  The add Button is, you know.
Ben: is now labeled, but I think that might be a bug and talk back, and
Ben: the apps fall. But I could be wrong. You know what I mean.
Interviewer: but you're using the Ocr system from talk back, and it detects like that button. Yes, yes, it does. Yes, hmm. got it.
Interviewer: Okay, so this let's imagine you downloaded this app
Interviewer: and
Interviewer: we want to store and monitor your expenses. Say, today, you went to the groceries. You went to a restaurant to eat.
Interviewer: or you bought something from Amazon. and you want to add those expenses.
Interviewer: and then I'll see like
Interviewer: Or let's say today you did that yesterday. You edit some other expenses, so can you go about like how you would do that yourself.
Ben: Totally add, expect button
Ben: and the transaction probably had 20. I've done listing the data.
Ben: everyone, the data I drop down drop down list product carefully the data
Ben: I'm listed
Ben: double tap, the page labels available every 3 things to do.
Ben: double detrimental characters and boxes.
Ben: I really hope that, if possible. double tapes got and convention
Ben: category product category listed
Ben: double check.
Ben: and then when I double, tap on it, when I double tap on the the category.
Ben: a drop down and nothing happens.
Ben: Technical transaction date.
Ben: but even 3, and riddle and riddle. So there's 2. There's 2 boxes that say. enter info year, and I'm not sure which one is which.
Ben: And fashion data.
I did. But really next month
Ben: some packs. And then there's a
so kind of like.
Ben: So so everybody says, anybody read.
Ben: So that was Canada
Ben: double-time detection labels available to type a little better detectors.
No.
Interviewer: okay. In this case, what would you do?
0. 0. Give me
Ben: period
0 0,
Ben: adding 50 like a dollar sign transaction 20. But next month selected the day.
and so so so
Ben: stop, share button windows and you expenses this month and expect total expenses.
Ben: Did you realize what the what the announcement was? Oh, yes, yeah, yeah, yes. It says your wallet is empty.
Ben: Had money performed in medical?
You want it.
Ben: we can add.
Interviewer: thank you.
Ben: Addict setting. Add to add it up.
Ben: Addica, yeah.
Ben: Period 0, 0, 0 0 editing. And you want edit. What does it your text and share and edit edit on. But you want to contain, though what does it want to go?
Ben: Stop there? But with those
Ben: admin
Ben: still the dropdown list.
Ben: Let me try and go into the settings. Let me try turning off the Ocr. And see if that fixes it, you know.
Interviewer: Sure
Ben: always by screening poppy settings. double time to aggravate and pump and take on some stuff and plus the best amount of velocity for some control customer.
Ben: I don't know
Ben: automatic descriptions, photographs, images, and textile images, illuminati.
This is correct.
Ben: One of them
Ben: automatically describe here to select, not select the Lita, Ok and select radio, but selected of radio selected. You can still get the script to Lita. Well, but click on the script. Cancel the leader.
Ben: Somebody going here kind of agent
Ben: still does not work.
Ben: I don't know what's going on here.
Double drop down list, product, dropdown list.
Ben: Yeah, it's not. It's not working.
Ben: So I'll type in Amazon.
FAT.
Ben: Amazon
Ben: like done. And then what
Ben: confession looks like go ahead and transaction, right here, sound good
Ben: right here, please create so
Ben: I need to go. Yeah, there were no credits. I need to go to budget category
budget categories. What options category name.
Ben: So I'm gonna click on this button only one button, which I believe is the add button.
Interviewer: Umhm. And how did you know that?
Ben: I just I just. I just. I just guess, because there was the there wasn't.
Ben: There was the
Ben: unlabeled button before and said, add.
Interviewer: Yeah. Yeah.
Ben: So I'm guessing. Yeah, that's the same button.
Interviewer: You know, at the bottom. So
Ben: they were from the review of 50 category. Name that category name
Ben: shopping. That's a
Ben: budget
Ben: showing number keyboard 121 with the number of keyboard.
Ben: but with a number 1 0 period, 10, period, period period, 0, 0
Ben: budget navigate
Ben: what's expected. But but but my space offenses. Double type of the opening
Ben: shuffle present. How do you
Ben: 0%, like all dollars totally expensive. And and got that list shopping?
Ben: Okay, I see. So. Yes, the categories
Ben: here reflect the categories of the
Ben: of the budget category. Does that make sense?
Interviewer: Yeah, but it wasn't intuitive on your first try. Right? No, it wasn't. No, no.
Interviewer: it's technical, that is awesome
Ben: until we get my airline clip.
Ben: November the end.
Ben: Then it comes up.
Ben: Amazon.
Ben: Your text, anybody next September. So so something
Ben: add transaction.
Ben: Should I add another category or.
Interviewer: yeah, let's let's do something for food, and then at a new expense like Mcdonalds.
Ben: Double after activation, open navigation
Ben: money. But categories but a category
Ben: budget categories.
Ben: Am I going to add a new category double check?
Interviewer: I think our screen froze. Because I'm only seeing
first page.
Ben: Okay, budget, for example.
Interviewer: because you're you're in budget categories. Now, right?
Ben: Yeah, what kind of progress are? Zoom.
Ben: I'm only seeing like the first homepage. Oh, I'm sorry
Ben: one and update.
Ben: I'm so sorry. I do not know what happened there, because I did not
Ben: just connect it back, connect it
Ben: 1B s. Let me try. I'm so sorry. Let me.
Interviewer: They're good. Too much.
Ben: Zoom 20 or 20. The list of zoom extends, dismiss, resize, dismiss. double at at
Ben: so
Ben: perfect feeling that comes
Ben: money. Yeah. But you haven't shared your screen
Ben: and activated
Nope.
Ben: adding a path budget category as well.
Ben: That's for me, budget like a maximum amount of
Ben: so next
Ben: zoom, money, manager, picture, picture and picture zoom meet money manager 20 or 20B min.
Ben: Please. Hat, please, please. Hats.
Ben: zoom.
Ben: hurricane, double, hurricane back and hurricane like hurricane. or to urgent victims, neighbor, double epitomic
Ben: share, but share buttons, share buttons, webinar bookmark screen.
Ben: double tap that cancel out system, be live
Ben: back to where we are.
Ben: Double type, that double tap follow the
A, a
Ben: budget price of maximum amount of money in the statute is annually at about middle budget.
Ben: $100,
Ben: 0 middle number people. 0 stop share one number. Here's like the Max addigante
Ben: Attica. You gotta take Attica
Ben: independent money venture. What? What does like? What does anybody else?
Ben: But it wasn't like.
Ben: stop share button. Yeah, share audio. And it's not doing spaces. There's nothing expensive in
Interviewer: to come out.
Ben: Yeah, I use the plan. I use that as a talk back, you know.
Ben: Is it like down and left. Yes, yes.
Ben: coming from Pennsylvania.
Ben: Shall we hit which usable in the Rt. Mine system?
Yup will be timing on it?
Ben: Barbara County, Capitol d.
Interviewer: I don't know if you can fit Burger King. It's like 10
Ben: letters. Oh, oh,
Ben: yeah, you can. You can add burgers without the space. Just one word.
Ben: Do you like Burger King? Which which one's your favorite
Ben: walker, you know.
Interviewer: Well, for? Yeah, that's yeah.
It is one
Ben: I know at this expense. For, like yesterday.
Ben: What is that?
Interviewer: Can you add this request or or this expense for yesterday
Ben: selected today? September? There's been even 2 days since. Yeah, that confession.
Interviewer: Can you edit one of the categories like the food categories to say, restaurant?
I can go with that again.
Ben: but but sometimes I think
Ben: I don't have to aggregate on the panel. That box and we name it
middle name.
Ben: Yeah.
see.
I believe our premium.
Ben: Please
thank you. Mark
Ben: trustee. Pardon as we're present
a a restart restart by Emily. You know
Ben: he was great professor, manager space, we say, Alderman.
Ben: not yet. What not? If we don't edit.
did you.
Ben: There we go.
Ben: Please say about we stay out.
please. Barbecue you. do you? Deep. please? Likely
Ben: at at TT.
Ben: Sure. Wait. It's alright. Yeah.
Ben: Analyzed like anyone. But don't.
Ben: Can you check? Can you check what the transaction you made
Interviewer: for each of the categories?
Ben: And yeah, they wanted
Ben: shopping, and whatever thing goes on. $100.
Ben: What number like?
Interviewer: those those are the budgets for the individuals. But I want to see, or you want to see, like what expenses you already made for those categories? How did you know? Like you can go to this page.
Interviewer: is it from our experience or
Ben: cause? It's a double tap to activate.
Interviewer: Got it.
Interviewer: Now. There's also another feature called Budget Plans, where you can plan for something like next month. So can we add a budget plan.
Ben: double tap and activating open navigation goal.
Ben: But yes, budget click and budget plans. I know it.
Ben: Top share of the deputy wallet contains enough money for this man.
Ben: But definitely, this canvas basket. But definitely, yeah, but like, but I'm gonna
Ben: but I'm right there. But
Ben: double tap to edit
Ben: showing that which us, I believe, the November Age Hotel.
Ben: You can just write random.
Ben: Please beep. Please
Ben: eat Daddy, eat best tea.
Ben: planned dismay testing plan dispatch
Ben: TWAT. KAL.
Beverly bleeding.
Ben: Please keep a a best tape and please buy.
Ben: please, the the budget. Yeah. But I shall show it.
Next slide 7. Here we go.
Ben: 0 0 0 0 testing
Ben: anyone do next month.
Ben: I don't have no refunding of anybody. Be
Ben: October eighteenth, 2020, October 20,B s 20, but October, but October fifteenth, focusing October fifteenth, 2020, October, Saturday, October fifteenth, 2020.
Ben: Here we have fashion.
Ben: navigation.
Interviewer: all right. can I add another plan?
Ben: Yup. more options. puppet level
Ben: settings, settings.
Ben: Can't. I can't tell you that is awesome.
DDF function, value
Ben: part RE,
Ben: and a complete coming through canned description
Ben: the with the best.
Just
Ben: believe. At least, that's to be the best.
Ben: Connell Stacey. Space. Yes, that's
Ben: please. Nice a
Ben: space a DDE.
Ben: The the least best. The the plants budget plan 2023% lands budget oversight.
Ben: Meet me. Come in.
Interviewer: Let's make it $30.
Ben: Oh, Gotcha screen leader.
Ben: Wednesday, September. But anybody be activated? Selected?
Give me a me
Ben: since September, September 38. I need some some bad annotation. And then, second.
Ben: yeah, that is successfully, narrowly, after those 2 plans here.
Interviewer: Yeah. So there is a thing in budget plans that. Lets you
Interviewer: know, like what plants
Interviewer: like if your wallet has enough money for it and if the deadline has passed, can you determine which ones are which?
This is the best of $2023 3 point. Oh.
Interviewer: that's the definitely, the definitely the well, it can take more options. Your body contains enough money for this plan. Well, I did not take the money for this plan.
but then, when it was never back. but then, when you just hand them back.
Ben: I don't know why it says that even though it's
Ben: there's no one hasn't passed yet.
Why do you think that says that?
Ben: Probably just a generic message I'm guessing.
Hmm, hmm.
Interviewer: yeah, it's it's like color coordinated or color coded.
Ben: Yeah, Umhm.
Interviewer: it doesn't really help.
Interviewer: All right.
Interviewer: Let's see.
Interviewer: So can you check how much in total. You've spent this month.
Ben: Yes.
what's what's this project? What's success?
Ben: More options and your expenses is like shopping 50 point reserves button.
Ben: Unfortunately, it doesn't tell me, doesn't tell me the total expenses.
Interviewer: I see the topic isn't going to
Interviewer: the the element that is actually showing is showing 70.
Interviewer: But talk Pegasus.
Interviewer: Alright. so another thing would be
Interviewer: so there are a few other. Let's say
Interviewer: he chose, like
Interviewer: budget sorry budget analysis and monthly expense analysis.
Ben: Yes, overnight.
Ben: but monthly. Expensive budget plans, monthly expenses, analysis, budget analysis, monthly, expensive enough. Check open navigation, more monthly monthly exporages, Muslims.
Ben: I don't see anything in this web, you know.
Interviewer: Let me show it to you. Okay.
Ben: is there anything else in this? more options? And as about it.
Ben: expenses, analysis, title
Interviewer: got it? This should be another button at the very end. Can you focus on that? Or is talk like not able to?
Ben: No, it's not able to
Interviewer: let me. Kind of go to the other analysis. Budget analysis.
Ben: Okay, perfect analysis.
Ben: Get open by starting, finding your expenses for category as well. If the employees midfallen was spent. The next value was 50 article.
Ben: okay, version, something shopping. We sparked it.
Ben: Shopping camera. But shopping, reserve shopping, 0 slash 0 for more information.
Ben: That's our website.
Ben: Annotation. Let me stop, stop! Share!
Ben: What does the web you announce
Ben: what you said?
Interviewer: Well, what does the wave view announce? Cause I couldn't quite catch it.
Ben: What view and advice? What's the right? Probably title. You're expenses which has some voice. Mph.
Ben: same minimum value, maximum value. Something like that. Right? Yes, yes, yes, yes, Umhm.
Interviewer: do you do you have any idea of what it is actually trying to convey?
Interviewer: Can you like? What do you think this page is trying to convey.
Ben: It's trying to convey like, how much like, how much you spend in a month?
Interviewer: Yeah, yeah, yeah. In a month.
Ben: and it's doing that via via charts.
Interviewer: Okay? So so it announced the chart
Ben: and announced that there was a chart. Yes, what is your you know opinion about like charts and stuff?
Ben: I feel like they
Ben: usually about 99.9% of the time. They're not accessible.
Interviewer:  what? What is a good alternative for you.
Ben: A good alternative would be a table.
Ben: So be a table. So it have. You know the expenses that you know the first column and the second column would be the
Ben: I'm sorry would be the expense name first column.
Interviewer: That makes sense. Can you visit the website?
Ben: Yeah, from visit our website
Ben: links available. You just have me 3 favorites for you
call back in 3 places
Ben: double tap website and
Ben: 0%
Ben: money mentor fiscal. There we go.
Interviewer: and can you change any settings but the change in settings for for what?
Interviewer: Or let's say, adding expenses for the categories? But there there is like a settings. Option
Ben: doesn't let me do anything when I
Interviewer: got it.
Interviewer:  okay.
Interviewer: So before we end, can you tell me?
Interviewer: You what
Interviewer: you think about this app? What are you reviews? What issues? If you face any?
Ben: Yeah. I feel generally the the the app is overall. Pretty good.
Ben:  I would definitely change the color coding to the actual text.
You know, and the make sure that the total expenses.
Ben: Text
Ben: is the total expenses. Text is is labeled, as you know.
Ben: labeled, as is
Ben: the the the value
Ben: of the total expenses labeled and able to be seen with talkback, because right now I'm not able to be, and that I'm not able to see
Ben: the total expense. You know. Number, you know what I mean.
Interviewer: But otherwise the app was
Ben: usable and accessible. Yes, yes, Umhm.
Interviewer: okay.
Interviewer:  And the labeling. I know. You say that there was some unlabeled buttons, but otherwise they weren't that obtrusive?
Ben: Yeah, no. Yeah.
Ben: yeah, I mean, like, i'd say, label, the, add button, you know, just so
Ben: if you don't have the talkback recognition on it'll still be. No, it'll be read as an Add Button, because some people might wonder what that enabled Button is.
Interviewer: and when you edit a transaction you realize which
Interviewer: text wanted to to add the expense.
Interviewer: Do you remember like how how you came to realize that?
Ben: Yeah. So
Ben: Yes, I realize that the first field
Ben: was for the title, and the second one was for the dollar, because II
Ben: tapped on the second field and it popped up a keyboard for the dollar for the dollar amount. So it was like, Okay.
Ben: alright. So then, I obviously, you know, assume that the first first one
Ben: first field is for the title
Ben: per the expense title
Interviewer: done.
Ben: but a clear label would be helpful.
Interviewer: you know, cause their label would be helpful.
Interviewer: What do you think about the the calendar
Interviewer: in those adding transactional plan?
Ben: I feel like I feel like the calendar is pretty good. It's one of the better
Ben: the better ones I've seen. Honestly.
Interviewer: You know, and you know, it actually works
Ben: really well. I can move between dates. I can select a date. I can move between months.
Interviewer: you know. And
Ben: you know, yeah, you know, and figure out which which they don't want to add, and then click it.
Ben: and it tells me selected.
Ben: and then I double tap on the add expense. But
Ben: or a transaction button.
Interviewer: so you can use the
Interviewer: touch gestures or explore by touch, to go around the different dates like, yes.
Interviewer: got it
Interviewer: all right before we end. Can you go to notescribe again?
Ben: Yes.
Ben: oh, awesome resonance! Oh, my team of Betty! And let's Bethanya. Money meant no. Oh, appointment, accessibilities, default back settings.
No, no, it's gone 60.
Ben: Yeah. You can just disable the service. Navigate up.
Ben: Don't cry, stop! Stop, sir! Annotation, stop service accessibility, navigate notes, going service
Ben: notes, use no options, use no stop notes. Likes to cancel. Stop.
Interviewer: you can also uninstall it after after alright another thing I have to disclose is that the app that you use? The money manager can open source application. So you know.
Interviewer: the the main application doesn't have
Interviewer: some of the issues. Some of them were injected by us for a research purpose. So I have to make that disclosure so that you don't think that the actual app is has. But it does have some issues. I won't say is is fully good. It has no issue.
Interviewer: Yeah. Otherwise it's good.
Ben: Exactly. Yeah. Yeah.
Interviewer: Alright. Thank you. Thank you for your time and the insights. You're welcome. Hope to hope to see you again.